avez-vous déjà menti à votre employeur
alors j'ai les réponses de chacun par
exemple Valérie ben m'a dit non bah non
parce vous êtes mon ami donc je m pas
bravo Valérie bravo Daniel Mor a dit oui
oui mais pas pas ici mais dans une autre
vie ça m'est arrivé j'étais à Roland
garous j'ai dit que j'étais malade ou
des trucs comme
ça Jean-Marie Bigard a dit non bravo
Jean-Marie bravo
Jean-Marie dit oui c'est la base tous
les autres sont des hypocrites oui bien
sûr quand vous dites employur vous
parlez de qui ouais bah on a eu à
l'époque de ou non c'est à l'époque de
d'autres d'autres d'autres Jobs bien sûr
mais mais mais tout le monde a menti à
son B je vous parle de ma personne vous
Anouna ouis vous AZ
déjàduér j'en ai pas le
souvenir non non calmez-vous je peux
vous êtreès extrêmement sévère Gilles
verd déjà venti oui mais pas à vous mais
vous de toute façon même si j'en avais
la tentation vous devineriez que c'est
un mensonge donc je n'essai pas mais oui
avant j'ai menti oui von tu m'as déjà
menti hein
quoi tu vu que tu avais mis oui non moi
j'ai omis j'ai peut-être omis de trois
détails mais est-ce que au maître c'est
mentir ch ou est- pas dire quand on
oublie de mettre son slip on est pas
bien est-ce que pas le dire c'est mentir
bien sûr au mtre c'est au MRE c'est
pareil hein au niveau de la langue
française au MRE ça veut dire
voilà comment tu es au niveau de la
langue française tu es comment tu
comment ah non c'est juste pour savoir
comment tu te trouves bien tu te trouves
bien ça ve dire la même chose au mare
oui bon bah c'est bien c'est bien gu
bien sûr jamais jamais mon ch bien sû
Géraldine bien sûr n jamais jamais bravo
Géraldine je vous offre notre côe ce
soir a déjà menti ou à qui à moi oui je
en fait tous les défaut t les je vous
menti mais si je vous ai dit que j'étais
pas là parce que je devais j'étais
malade j'étais parti à Los Angeles je
suis revenu
immédiatement bah oui fais gaffe toi
je suis honnête préf quoi préféz des
gens des gens qui fais gaffe on est
dernier fais gaffe toi ah tiens Valérie
ben combien de fois avez-vous été arrêté
par la police zéro bah ouais zéro zé
avez-vous déjà fait vos besoins dans un
lieu public oui j'ai fait pipi une fois
où
ça une seule fois dans ta vie tu as fait
pipiah ouais sur l'autoroute et le temps
je me suis arrêté sur le on on doit pas
le faire sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
mais vraiment j'en pouvais plus donc
derrière la portière pipi quoiou mais
tout le monde le fait tout le temps ça
qui alors la question avez-vous à quelle
fréquence vous rendez-vous dans un lieu
de culte par mois euh qui a répondu B
naï tu as mis tu as mis quoi jamais bah
par mois non j'y vais pour les grandes
fêtes mais j'y vais pas tous les mois
c'est moche euh c'est moche Daniel Morau
une fois bah en moyenne mais c'est vrai
que dès dans un mieux d'aller prier toi
pour trouver un mec toutes les semaines
he t les si étais toi j'y vais de 8h à
minuit sans déconner toi tu quoi je fais
tout moi je fais toi tu devis faire
toutis église mosqué synagogue
temp normalement tu dois faire toute la
journée tu dois faire des tours comme ça
j'ai brûer des cierges parfois ouais
ouais brûle des cierges Jean-Marie
Bigard ah quatre fois par mois oui ou
plus bravo oui bah je compte surtout les
dimanches quoi la messe d'accord c'est
bien voilà c'est ça vous vous êtes
choqué non du tout je trouve ça bien
c'est bon c'est vrai une fois ouais une
fois une fois par mois Mo mais quel
mytho bah qu'est-ce que vous connaissez
de ma vie non non mais vous avez vous
allez à l'église vous vous êtes déjà à
l'église ouais
ouais passé devant église j'adore les
églises figurez-vous ça n'a rien à voir
tiens Gilles Vernez jamais zé ah non
c'est par moi zé par moi zé là fa tu vas
où parce que en revanche par exemple
j'ai déjà fait mes besoins dans un lieu
public régulièrement là j'aurais répondu
oui on s'en fout que tu es chier dans
un non mais chier sur le pér non juste
euh toi tu vas où alors maintenant estce
que tu t'appelles Gill et Souleiman ou
oui bah je ne vais pas asseer à la si
c'est un reproche il est fondé je ne
vais pas assez à la mosquée je vais
essayer d'y aller plus fais gaffe hein
je te dis je vais vérifier non je vais
essayer d'y aller plus bien sûr sûû tu
vas voir je vérifier mais je j'essaie de
m'améliorer bah tu as beaucoup de trucs
où tu dois t'améliorer euh Guillaume
Ganton euh euh Guillaume Ganton
avez-vous déjà eu une relation sexuelle
au travail oui bah oui hein pourquoiette
histoire bah régulièrement quoi
régulièrement mais où mais à quelle
heure quand sentend avec quelqu quand on
s'entend bien avec quelqu'un au travail
c'est normal de de Ken dans la bonne
humeur
non mec est fou en
fait cette histoire avec quelqu'un qu'on
connaît à T PMP non non est-ce qu'il
quelqu'un qu'on connaît non ah vous
peut-être ouais bah oui oui il connait
tout le monde moi je connais il conna
tous les BA qui le BA quoi che qui est
le bail he le bail quand il commence à
bégayer c'est que vous connaissez ouais
he non mais c'est quoi oh oui peut-être
vous l'avez peut-être déjà vu une fois
tu veux me le dire dans l'oreille euh
ouais vas-y comme ça on va vite savoir
ouais bien non mais je on sera vite au
courant ouais bien
sûr il va parler très
fort
[Musique]
ah savais pas ça je savais pas ça
t'étonne ma couille
hein
tu vois c'est pas un patron comme les
autres un autre patron tu vois fait pas
ça ici jeanluc de
laactin tu as fait le bilan ouais il a
un bon petit boule quand même bah oui
c'est vrai non mais c'est fou euh
Géraldine quoi ah là tu peux reparler
non là c'est très grave ah vous voulez
que je reparle ah oui avez-vous coucher
ou embrasser le ou la partenaire d'une
amie oui quoi oui oui oui il y a
longtemps j'espère il longs dis pas que
tu
patoche non juste des baisés un peu
langoureux quoi ouais lors de soirée un
peu décadent des soirées décadent c'est
vrai oui bah oui des copines par exemple
géraline tu as le droit de reparler
j'aime bien mais que des filles en
revant jamais des garçons ah ouais ouais
ah chaud des meufs voilà des baisé tu as
baisé
qui excuse-moi euh ah quoi à quelle
fréquence jouez-vous à des jeux d'argent
par mois Daniel quatre fois ou plus ben
je joue au loto toutes les
semaines
on s'imagine bien qu'avec ta tenue
vestimentaire tuas pas
gagné
sal on me l'a fait pas là on sait que
bon il il y a pas eu de non mais c'est
sûr non mais voilà c'est sûr c'est sûr
Castaldi tiens je vais me pencher sur
son truc aussi c'est magnifique ce test
je sais pas ce que j'adore euh ah ah ben
lui Castaldi Castaldi je même pcher sur
lui tiens chil Verdes d'abord non non
non toi tu as jamais rien eu toi non
mais tu un tar toi vous arri-il de
parler dans le dos de vos collègues non
quelle fréquence jouez-vous à des jeux
d'argent jamais avez-vous déjà une
relation sexuelle au travail non
avez-vous déjà trompé votre partenaire
non tu as une vie de
merde non mais franchement avez-vous
déjà eu une expparation sexuelle tarifée
non alors o tu es menteur je pense que
tu es menteur tu sais quoi je viens de
comprendre ouais ça comprendre beaucoup
de choses le
nez mais je te le dis non mais non mais
arrête du OUI à exhibé vos parties
g par Gén fait tout me fait l'
fait franchement tu vois pas avez-vous
déjà couché embrasser le ou la
partenaire d'un ami ou d'une amie non
frère non mais P oui c'est un menteur ou
c'est un pigeon là je suis sur Raymon
par contre il y a des oui
[Applaudissements]
partout mais sans rigoler vous a de
parler dans le dos de vos collègues oui
vous avez-vous déjà eu une relation
sexuelle au travail oui avez-vous déjà
exhibé vos partis public oui avez-vous
déjà trompé votre partenaire oui avez-v
déjà une relation seu tarifé oui arrête
les deux il y a pas les deux derniers
c'est pas V con mon pote depuis 20 ans
Arte jamais payé arrête frère mais
j'étais là
[Applaudissements]
j c'est
cy c'est cy ton pote g V cro c'est ton
pote c'est c c non rmon c'est oh tu me
remets bah oui quelque chose qui payé
allez viens tu as pas quelque chose à me
dire dans
l'oreille les deux derniè après oui moi
j'ai dit j'ai dit la vérité sur le test
non frère change pas les réponses mais
frère je change les réponses parce que
malheureusement mal je connais la vérité
jamais payé tuas jamaiste arrêteas
jamais payé jamais même un petit peu
jamais un petit lead c'est
combien€ tu sais pas tu sais pas ce que
tu as loupé hein j'ai répondu moi c'est
bien vrai tout est vrai tu un Castaldi
ah euh bon alors lui bah lui
voilà alors lui que des mauvaises à
quelle fréquence vous rendez-vous dans
un lieu de culte jamais et après il
s'étonne de pas avoir de chance euh
avez-vous déjà volé oui ah ouais
personne ah oui c'est tout le monde je
répond moi j'ai une qualité c'est
l'honné ouais je sais vous avez une
qualité surtout c'est de faire des
conneries euh vous arri-il de parler
dans le dos de vos collègues oui à
quelle fréquence jouezvous à des jeux
d'argent par mois 30 à 40 fois
si le sa de jours avez-vous déjà exhibé
vos parties génitales dans un lieu
public oui mais personne l'a
vu avez-vous déjà trompé votre
partenaire oui avez-vous déjà une
relation sexuelle tarifée oui bien sr
avez-vous déjà couché ou embrassé le
partenaire d'un ami ou d'une amie oui ou
Castaldi sachez que vous êtes le pire
parce que la pire note c'est Castaldi la
plus pure c'est Benaim et le moins pur
c'est Castaldi pas étonnant euh c'est
pas ét et Daniel a pas compris les
questions et vous voule
faire s'il vous PL sil vous plaît s'
vous plaî AZV déjà menti votre employur
c'est vousmême non non non pas toujour
il toujours été
patronant ouiou tu faais ce que tu
voulais mais tu as été employé combien
de fois avez-v été arrêté par la
police
alors
attend
tu peux
répondre c'est de la merde ce
test avez-vous déjà monté à votre
employeur alors donc vous le faites chez
vous également avez-vous déjà Monti avec
votre employur non non alors non c'est
c'est zéro point on marque zéro ceux qui
ont dit oui ça sera tris points pour eu
ah d'accord combien de fois avez-vous
été arrêté par la
police de de deux fois deux fois si pour
les papiers ouais deux fois non bon c
fois c fois voilà ah c fois c'est 7
points c'est plus de trois oui c'était
ça plus de trois c'est 7 points dire tu
vas pas commencer à me reprendre ça va
me faire
chierci tu conseilles d'abandonner ce
ton
agressif
tu alors euh ensuite al donc pour les
gens qui qui s' mettent zé c'est zé
points 1 c'est TR points 2 c'est 5
points et plus de 3 c'est 7 points c'est
déjà TR est-ce que vous avez déjà fait
vos besoins dans un lieu public bah oui
ou même dans des chouses it non mais moi
j'ai la vité moi je peux faire le guide
du du
chilleur ou j'ai chier par les
deux partout partout partout ou moi
aussi alors oui c'est qu points c'est
beau et non c'est zé points ça va et
comment vous faites
pour sachez que dans ma camionnette j'ai
toujours
cam quel Tomy mais que dans ma
camionnette j'ai toujours des lingettes
je vous dis ah je peux vous dire que
j'ai les fraises une propreté vous
pouvez manger dessus ah vous aimez le
papier toilette humide vous aimez le
papier toilette humide parce que vous
devez vous connaître papier toil papier
toilettes humide j'ai toujours du papier
toilette aussi dans la voiture j'ai les
deux ou attention micos parce que quand
c'est humide ça prolifère non non vous
inquiétez pas ça rien de
prolifère sous contrôle merci tout est
sous contrôle vous inquiétez pas j'ai
pas un champignon dans les fesses c'est
important alors à quelle fréquence vous
rendez-vous dans un lieu de culte par
mois FO tu es fou come il est F qu fois
par mois mais il est fou ce mec là mais
il ti tar mec là tu crois quoi tu crois
que ça tombe tu crois que ça tombe comme
ça TOI d'ailleurs tu devrais plus y
aller hein pe y aller alors qure fois ou
plus c'est zé points tu V aller où toi
ah moi je devrais aller au moin 30 ans à
la synagogue quand même
quoi oui- raconte bah oui bah oui bah je
je vais je vais pas je vais pas à
l'église moi ah oui bah non ah oui fait
Chabbat vendredi j'ai entendu ça
vendredi mais frère mais euh bah quoi
frère bah tu tombes pas du ciel Salomon
votre père il est rab enfin quand même
arrêtez oui grandmère
mais il est en dépression ah ouais ou en
dépression je crois que tu vraiment pas
bien toi moi je dis fais tout toi fais
tout dans ton CAD il faut tout faire
donc vous vous es quatre fois ou plus ça
fait zéro point pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est trois fois c'est un
point deux fois c'est trois points une
fois c'est 5 points et jamais c'est 7
points est-ce que vous avez déjà volé
Cyril allez-y
empruné oui peut-être une fois par mal
qui parce que c'est des gens ou dans un
magasin un magasin un proche ou un
inconnu ah oui les TR
TR c'est combien de points les trois un
proche c'est 5 points un magasin 4
points un inconnu TR points mais parce
que
croyz mag 3 an j'ai pris une guim faut
dire la
vérité
ok est-ce que ça vous est-ce que vous
parlez dans le dos des gens non la moi
par MO je par
alors moi franchement je parle pas dans
le dos par contre je vous
défonce à quelle fréquence vous jouez au
jeu d'argent par mois pas beaucoup non
jamais ouais mais vraiment non même pas
pas par mois jamais ou jamais j
franchement je joue pas tellement pour
les gens c'est zé points pour jamais un
point pour une fois trois points pour
deux fois 5 points pour quatre fois et
plus de qure fois on arrêter le test ici
parce que je vois les questions les
questions qui arrivent après allez on
arrête allez on arrête allez s'il vous
plaît on arrête t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
al
non non non non le P réclame ce que les
gens veulent he alors la France entière
réclame un peu transparence est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu une relation sexuelle
au
travail je vais le dire au français je
peux répondre je vous connais hein quoi
je peux répondre je vous connais allez-y
répondez benah je
dirais
pas mal non
non jure je rappelle vous êtes dernière
de la classe alors ça jamais alors je je
crois que je vais je vais quitter
l'émission non mais oui mais c allez oui
oui c'est trois points trois points et
non c'est c'est 0 point allez allez on
s'en fout des points avez-vous déjà
exhibé vos parties génitales oui bon ça
on sait hein oui c'est 5 points ça on le
sait bah oui bah oui non mais voilà euh
avez-vous déjà trompé votre partenaire
oui la base non non non non non il y a
que des oui à la fin donc ok euh
d'accord 5 points pour oui mais bon très
bien vous avez déjà eu une relation
sexuelle tarif non alors non d'accord
vous êtes pas de non c'est pas votre
trucit plus spontané plus spontané cette
réponse que juste celle d'avant JIS non
jamais jamais jamais mon C et alors la
dernière question C est-ce que vous avez
déjà coucher ou embrasser la partenaire
d'un
am vous êtes pas à l'aise c'est même
pas sachant que sachant que sans charier
je comprends pas la question peut-être
Jean-Michel mer il vous avz embrassé la
meuf d'un pote ah Jean-Michel oui bah
ouies en
train que Jean-Michel il a comprend oui
je pense il comprend la question ce qu'
vous concerne je crois Jean-Michel ma
chevauchage quoi
de tu sais que je te dis mais c'est
dingue toi tu devrais te faire tout
petit mais non mais juste embrasser vous
avezêtre vous est arrivé du bout des
lèvres rigol bout des
lèvresage pour un gage pour un gage
alors faut savoir que le mec qui est
quand même plus le plus SP avec moi dans
l'émission avec Guillaume c'est Raymon
tu as l'air de m'accbler de précédent
arrêter de te défendre les C dernières
ell devrai même pas exister derniè
question fais gaffe
toi je te vois rigoler làbas r rigole
voilà il faut savoir cy que entre 0 et
20 points vous étiez une personne pure
ou entre 21 et 40 vous étiez une
personne humaine avec ces défautité
voilà et au-delà de 40 41 c'était une
personne immonde allez vous faire
soigner en l'occurrence vous vous avez
30 points vous êtes
humain
je